whole i haven't seen you in a little bit
how was your summer did you have a good
summer i haven't seen you guys i am i
went to fire island actually i spent a
bit of time out there this summer i've
never been to fire island is it was it
fun it's fun yeah it's um got it's sort
of you know this long bit of land and
we're on the sort of family oriented
area but there is an area that's quite
um like very famous for being gay it's
the gay uh part of the island called um
the cherry grove and anyway my boyfriend
and i went out there um and he got he
got a little bit harassed he got
harassed
your boyfriend is bobby cannavale right
yes and uh he he's from board where he's
from boardwalk empire very good looking
fellow and he also
he was on will and he's on will and
grace yes so we would walk past that
which is a very popular show obviously
but we would um walk past these groups
of guys and they would just like start
staring and then have a little summit
and sort of talk to each other
and do this whole like bit and start
like taking photos and yelling at his
name like
i thought they were sketching something
oh oh yes doing a little sketch but the
island was that part of the island was
so much more beautiful you know they
have better houses out in on this on the
cherry grove area and i was like let's
get a house here this next summer and he
was like i don't think i can handle it i
can't handle it he was getting very well
he's kind of a he's an icon because did
he had one of the first yeah i think
believe one of the uh two men kissing uh
on television yeah him and eric
mccormick so yes he's got quite the
following yes but i wasn't threatened
you weren't threatened
i'm just curious okay what do you do uh
for fun when you're on an island like
that for a while it can get boring
that's the one thing i'm i get jittery i
always want to be doing something new
what kind of things do you guys have
do you play monopoly do you play games
what do you do
heavily monopoly no we um we did some
bike riding we played a game which is
kind of fun called would you rather
i don't
would you rather so would you rather
this was a tough one we hit would you
rather have one arm for the rest of your
life
or a beard for the rest of your life of
your own
let's
pubes
it's not tough at all beard of puke yeah
yeah
but if you're a lady this is with my
girlfriends hey shave it right you know
no shake not allowed that's not what you
didn't say that well no there's no razor
guy i would take beard of pubes
really sure
yeah weird curly kind of oily well you
know you just get straightened why are
we talking about this would you rather
would you rather have one tooth for the
rest of your life or a hole with no like
no cartilage so it's like here
so one nostril one mono nostril what is
wrong with the two of you that's all i
how are you thinking of these one twos
are just all
one hole right there some drug problems
i'm gonna go with one tooth you think
yeah cause i just go into stores and go
you got corn
i like corn i would just do that oh and
i'd wear big overalls and say i like
corn
as well now i did want to mention your
boyfriend uh bobby canavelli likes to uh
occasionally post the embarrassing photo
of you
and you are i guess a sound sleeper
because he took this very candid shot
of you sleeping
and then tweeted this out to the world
right yeah that's a really nice photo
well first of all i'm curious do you
really take up that much of the bed
you look like you're how does he get it
you've been drugged or something i'm not
sure what was going on i mean not that's
a nice rumor to get out there
have some of this out
what
seriously uh he were you upset by that i
mean obviously you're very beautiful
upset no i thought that was early on as
well and i was like that you know what
would you do if someone posted a photo
of you like that just be happy for the
attention
guys here i am cool people sigh
conan you're naked and you have a beard
of pubes i don't care
and one arm and yeah